A major 2020 story broke over the weekend
and the assessments of the story could not
be more different even within the left.
So let's go through it.
I'll give you both perspectives and then I'll
tell you what I think makes sense.
Bernie Sanders has taken a first place lead
in a historically important poll out of Iowa.
The first state to vote in the 2020 democratic
primary Pete boot edge had taken the lead
in Iowa back in November.
Bernie Sanders has now surged ahead with 20%
support in the Des Moines register.
CNN poll, mayor Pete is at 16 Elizabeth Warren
now actually in second place at 17 so it's
Bernie 20 Warren 17 mayor Pete 16 Biden 15
this poll is considered the gold standard
by many.
Bernie is leading in the poll.
That is a very good sign for Bernie Sanders
that he could go onward and upward to the
admin to the a democratic nomination.
That's one view.
Okay.
There's another view which I'll present and
then we can discuss which is more relevant.
The other view is, hold on a second.
Half of Iowa caucus goers are not even fully
committed yet to any candidate at all.
Bernie has a slight lead among the half that
has decided and in addition there's the importance
of Iowa friend of the show, bill Cher, who
many of our progressive viewers love to hate,
has a piece out and bill argues Iowa matters
less than ever in 2020 now, please remember,
I'm just the messenger here.
I'm telling you what people are saying on
both sides and bill says the proof that Iowa
matters less than ever is that candidates
are spending less time than ever in Iowa.
This time around, if you look at 2004 2008
bill says, candidate is we're spending huge
amounts of time in Iowa this time there's
very little attention being paid because candidates
don't really believe it matters that much.
Biden hasn't been there lately.
Warren stops by on weekends.
Bernie is spending this entire week elsewhere
even though this is the first primary and
it's coming up.
And what bill share argues is that the DNC
did this on purpose.
The DNC pushed up the primaries after Iowa
and New Hampshire, Nevada and South Carolina
specifically to make the first two primaries
matter less.
There's also the issue that is a broader question,
which is Iowa is so white.
It tells us very little about what Democrats
are going to do nationally when they vote.
So these are the two sides.
This is such great news.
Bernie is going to get the nomination.
The other side is Iowa's irrelevant.
Bernie's leading within the margin of error.
This doesn't matter.
Uh, what is the truth about this?
Number one, Iowa does matter.
Less than many people are willing to admit.
Bernie being in first place in Iowa though
is a big deal because if the question is can
Bernie build momentum as the primaries get
rolling, uh, winning the first primary, proving
his viability, there's no better start to
a primary season than winning the first one.
So it is important in terms of momentum.
Iowa is a proof of concept for a campaign
of sorts.
Even though the South Carolina numbers are
going to be way different than Iowa, regardless,
because demographically South Carolina is
so very different.
So it's true.
I was very small.
It's followed up very quickly by other primaries
and it's not very diverse.
So the real takeaway here, and I hope you
know it, you get clicks by taking some hot
take.
That's an extreme position on one side or
the other.
The takeaway is a boring one, which is there's
no one statistic that tells us the full story
about an election.
I get all these people who email me, they
say, David, no one's talking about this.
The biggest gain in favor ability in the first
three primaries over the last three months
was Andrew Yang.
That means he's the guy who's going to win
and the best person to run against Trump in
a shoe in for the nomination, or I'll get
another one.
If you look only at polls done on weekends,
Bernie does best and weekend polling is more
reflective of who will really vote.
I'm making that one up.
So thus Bernie is the guy.
There is no one metric or polar calculation
that tells us the whole real story.
There's a degree of unpredictability here.
There's a degree of incomplete information.
Look at 2016 when we could say Hillary lost
because she didn't go to Wisconsin in the
last two months.
Hillary lost because James me did that press
conference about her.
Hillary lost because people were furious that
the DNC helped her get the nomination and
that got enough people to stay home that Trump
won Russian interference made it so that Hillary
lost the stock market performance in the two
weeks before the PR.
All of these things arguably matter and there's
no one thing that we can say explains what
happened or tells us what's going to happen
in 2020 life is just way more complex than
these analyses account for.
And so the takeaway is Bernie is leading an
Iowa and that's the best thing for him compared
to being in second place or in third place
or in fourth place.
He can win.
He has a lot of work to do.
Other States will go very differently than
Iowa, but what's clear is that anybody writing
Bernie off at this point and saying he cannot
win is just not operating in the world of
fact, and that's the big takeaway.
Now after the break, corporate media is panicking
about Bernie leading in Iowa.
Donald Trump is panicking about Bernie leading
in Iowa.
We'll deal with that after the break.
In the meantime, let me know what you think
by leaving a reply as a comment.
If you're watching on YouTube
or send me a tweet at deep Hackman, curious
to hear what people think